pleased to uh also welcome in right now
my next guest he is
the championship head coach of the
defending world champion los
angeles lakers he is fresh off of a win
against the minnesota timberwolves he is
frank vogel how are you coach
i'm good rich how are you doing i'm
doing well are you calling literally
from just down the street
at the lakers facility are we i'm
actually at my house
right now today okay cause i was gonna
invite you over
i know you know our protocols are you
know i think they're similar i was just
going to invite you over we're right
down the road
you know friends we can zoom from across
the street right i think that would be
california that would be such a 21st
century thing but yes
we could do that so uh let's get into uh
a little bit of the uh difference
between this year and obviously the
bubble
and and you having to deal with covert
protocols and getting into that
a little bit and we'll hit the wayback
machine a little bit and and then
and then linger in the present what has
been like this year to be a head coach
in the nba
uh in this pandemic outside of the
bubble
yeah well it's it's definitely been a
challenge you know um
you know obviously uh the the major
difference between the bubble and this
year is
is the travel um you know and then the
mindset
i think that uh you know you you're
really
back home you're back uh you know when
you when you go on the road
um you know you're not technically
allowed to leave your hotel
or do anything but the rules change
every two weeks
um you know so when you're in a bubble
you just kind of knew like this is this
is where i'm gonna be for the next three
months
you know and uh and there's me no travel
you're gonna play every other day
and you kind of fall into it into a
rhythm but you know to have these types
of uh
restrictions uh while dealing with a
more condensed schedule
and and traveling has just been uh it's
been a challenge
but uh you know it's something that
we're all in uh it's for the betterment
of
of the league and um you know we're all
trying to play our part to get through
this pandemic
and then let's talk about this year a
little bit how is anthony davis as you
and i
are talking right now chris haynes of
yahoo
had mentioned uh in a report that it
could be another month
until you get him back on the court
would that be uh accurate
well we'll see you know he's going to be
evaluated again uh towards the end of
the month
and and see where he's at you know we're
hoping that it's not going to be that
long but
um you know it's really going to be a
process of of building up his workload
and seeing how
uh how the cap responds and uh you know
things go well hopefully it won't be
that long
okay and so um is there uh any sense of
like look we got this there's no sense
in rushing him back because of the
nature of this
injury we got this if we're a three seed
four seed you know
five seed we'll deal with it um but it's
better to just
play the long game here is that a
sensibility that you guys are employing
right now
on this subject well well we just want
to make sure the injury's behind him
you know and and you know that's that's
the way we would be with uh with
all of our players with with any injury
you know it's uh the regular season is a
marathon
and um you know something like this with
uh with such an important
player uh you don't want to put him at
risk to
losing him longer term so um you know
we're going to take whatever time is
necessary to put the injury behind him
what have you learned about lebron james
being his coach that you didn't know
uh competing against him what have you
learned
you know i just think it's different to
see his iq
uh up front in his leadership his
ability to
to figure out a game or figure out a
stretch of the season or or
figure out a playoff series um you know
i've never been around a winner
uh of this level you know i don't know
if the the game has ever seen
someone that knows how to win at this
level um
you know he just has a you know a great
intellect for the game
and uh you know something that you know
competing against him but
but it's just different when you see it
up close can you give me an example of
that iq
something that you're like okay i just
saw that well um
you know it's you know i just think you
see it on a daily basis
you know whether it's uh in-game you
know
something that's hurting us like hey we
need to do this we do guys like having
another assistant coach out there
um you know or if it's a stretch of the
season you know for instance um
most recently with with anthony being
out he was carrying a heavy load and
um you know we knew we were going to be
in a period where we had to
adjust um you know and and learned to
live without anthony
and you know he he had the mindset like
you know after we came out of the gates
and lost a couple in a row
that he wanted to play more in the low
post and at the elbow
you know what i mean and uh defer some
of the ball handling uh responsibilities
during during a stretch uh while anthony
is out while we were short-handed
and um you know that that type of shift
in our office of philosophy
has given us uh some growth and allowed
us to get some traction yeah and for me
you know frank vogel here on the rich
eisen show when i i was on sportscenter
uh when he was when i was doing
highlights of his high school games
and it's just amazing to me to hear like
last night oldest player to ever have
back to back triple doubles and i'm like
i can't believe we're talking about
lebron james as the oldest
anything but here we are he's 36 he's
played half his life as an nba player
18th season he doesn't show any signs of
doing anything different
and then there's the sense that you just
mentioned is another assistant coach in
the huddle but how how
because you you i'm sure you've heard
all the conjecture and all the
yip yap and uh in my business uh of you
know
can't tell lebron what to do as a coach
and sometimes you might have to as a
coach say great idea but
let's try it my way how how does that
nuance work between you and
and lbj frank vogel no he's been
terrific in that regard it really has
been a partnership
between myself and him and our coaching
staff um
we collaborate on on decisions on a
daily basis
you know we we include both anthony m
and lebron you know our two captains are
two cornerstones
uh with with many of the sort of what
you call fence decisions
you know that we make throughout the
course of the season whether it's a game
plan or when to travel or
um you know whether we should have uh
you know practice or shoot arounds or
whatnot and
uh you know measuring work versus rest
those types of things
um because you know that the only thing
that matters to those guys is winning
you know so
um you know we've had a great a great
partnership um
you know plenty of times where um you
know he or anthony would feel one thing
and
we say hey we got to work or hey we got
to we got a double team or
we got to run you know this this type of
action and
you know they'll listen and and work
together with us it really has been a
great partnership
uh you know since our coaching staff was
put together here in l.a
and uh hopefully leads to uh another
positive playoff run
if i could if you could wave a wand if i
gave you a wand that you could wave and
and adam silva would have to make the
rule change that you
you utter as you wave the wand what
would that be frank vogel
to change a rule change um
what would that be could do with
anything to do with the replay
uh that you'd you'd want the two-minute
report gone you want you'd want a
four-minute report like
what do you got for me funny like
throughout the course of the season
there's a million of these things come
up right
and you always hear jeff van gundy on
the broadcast saying oh this has got to
change that's catching
but putting it being put on a spot i'm
not i'm not really sure one phone in my
head other than maybe
uh you know let's put a jeopardy timer
on the on the
replay yes you know what i mean like hey
it's 30 seconds you have 30 seconds to
look at it
and if you if it's not clear within 30
seconds then we move on with it
with how it was called because you know
you know your colleagues are stealing
timeouts that way you know that
i'm sure you've attempted that too frank
so you're you're suggesting the jeopardy
theme
length of time is what you're saying yes
and then you take the headset off when
whether you whether it's clear or not
you take the headset off and we keep
playing and you
and you don't form the answer in the
form of a question like
like what what is block right what is
charge right yeah well the refs look
right into the camera now so
they could they could ask a question
they could form it as a question
they do frank vogel of the los angeles
lakers here uh
on the rich eisen show all right so
let's get into a couple of things here
frank um about you um
what what is more prized possession for
you winning a championship as a head
coach
or appearing as a stupid human trick on
david letterman years ago
is that which one is more you know
appearing as a stupid human
uh on on the championship probably
so is that true you did you you appeared
on a letterman show in a stupid human
trick
years ago i was a child 13 years old um
you know learned some some ball spinning
tricks at a basketball camp
i came home and uh you know all moms
like to brag about what their kids are
doing um
you know they she showed me off to some
of her colleagues at work and
you know they they used to live in new
york city and try to get on the show
with things like that
so they gave us the number we made it
made a phone call and they said if he
can do what you're saying he can do
then we want him on the show immediately
and about five days later i was on
dave letterman's show spinning a
basketball brushing your teeth in front
of david letterman in a live studio
audience
at 30 rockefeller is that what it was
yeah and national tv which i didn't
really
grasp the concept of i just thought my
friends at school were going to see it
you know i didn't realize the whole
country is watching and really the whole
future uh internet uh
generation will be watching as well do
you remember who was on letterman as
guests
that night frank you know you know
what's so funny is mark albert was
actually
on young you know yes maybe he was in
1986
and he was doing like his yeah his
blooper sequences that he used to do
back in the day
um he was on and then uh there was an
italian comedian named roberto benini
which i don't think anybody really i
think he won an oscar he was an actor
won an oscar frank so
this generation would know him as sort
of an 80s version of borat
okay well because interesting and you
being a new jersey guy i watched seeing
marv at age 13 probably was big for you
because i'm going to stay yeah cool i'm
a staten island guy so
marv is my guy um last thing for you
apropos of nothing i notice these things
sometimes i'm afflicted by it
frank i i noticed that you guys uh
meaning
nba head coaches used to suit and boot i
mean it it was like
a fashion show uh with you dressing up
coat and tie and now now it's just like
what's in the closet you know and uh
i'm wondering have we seen the end of
coaches
dressing up in the nba because the
bubble last year you decided let's not
dress up and the league has given you
the opportunity to dress down
have we had the days of nba head coaches
suiting and booted are they over
frank i i don't know but i don't think
so
um i think we're all happy with what our
dry cleaning bill looks like
you know this year and last year it's a
lot better than it has been in the past
but um we all had the mindset um we
actually had
uh coaches association meeting about
this um
where we really most of us still prefer
uh to wear suits
really you know in this i would say
that's about 60 40.
but in this climate of uh of the
pandemic in the bubble not having having
dry cleaning and all that we did it last
year and right
because this year we're still
pandemic-oriented and with a lot of
restrictions they're just uh we decided
to go another year
uh with more of a relaxed attire okay
but
um i think the expectation is to return
to suits next year who's pounding the
table for no suits is it popovich who's
the leading that charge of no suits
which coach you know uh i forget where
pop was with it
um you know but you know i'm a suit guy
okay i remember taylor jenkins spoke up
about it carlisle was a
a chuck daley guy you know chuck daly
always talked about
um you know how you should look so he's
the president of the coach here
coaches association so yeah there's a
lot of us that just see the value in
that but but there's certainly a handful
uh
you know plenty that like the relaxed
bit too okay and i'm fascinated by this
last one
which coach do you think would maybe
break ranks and say screw it i'm wearing
a suit
and you just all show up and you're like
you're dressed in your workout clothes
and your
and your your colleague who you're
battling that night just shows up
literally like on a runway like all
suited and booted which which coach do
you think would go rogue
for that i've got my guess give me yours
frank come on
if it stays casual you're talking about
no if you somebody's just like where's
wants to wear the suit they're dying to
wear the suit they can't
go without wearing a suit another day
and they break ranks and you show up
you're like what gives i'm still dressed
in my workout clothes you're dressed in
your suit which coach
do you think would go rogan do that
which one yeah i
you know i really don't know all right
let's let's go with coach carl no
that's we
like his belt matches his his sneakers
right now which matches the mask
it's tucked in like you could see that
right you know that yeah that's a good
answer for sure okay good answer
everybody
we start with jeopardy we end with
family feud thanks for the call frank
greatly appreciate it let's do this
again take care
you better that's frank vogel head coach
of the world champion los angeles lakers
we talk about the important stuff here
on the rich isaac show
and we also glean that it's probably
going to be another
at least a couple weeks for anthony
davis
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here